The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
So for the course, we have
four days of lectures.
Today we'll try to convince
you that it was actually a
good idea to come here, why
randomized evaluation is such
a useful tool and why it's
superior to many other kinds
of impact evaluation.
Once we've convinced you that
it's a good idea to come here,
then we'll start going through
the nuts and bolts of actually
how to run randomized
evaluations.
Tomorrow we'll go over some
of the general design
possibilities.
The following day we'll go
into some more of the
technical aspects like sample
size and measurement.
The last day we'll kind of
discuss the fact that even in
randomized evaluations, things
can go wrong, and how
you deal with that.
And throughout the entire course
as you're learning
this, you'll be incorporating
what you learn by designing in
step with the lectures your own
randomized evaluation in
the groups that you've
been preassigned.
So if you check out your name
tags, you'll see that you have
a group number.
Find other people with the
same color and number and
those will be your
group members.
We tried to put you together
in ways that made sense.
So we tried to have people who
were interested in agriculture
work with other people
within agriculture.
And over the course of the four
days, you'll be designing
your own randomized
evaluation.
And on the last day, on
Saturday, you will be
presenting your evaluation
to the entire group.
So that is pretty much
what to expect over
the next five days.
Have I forgotten anything?
Then let me reintroduce
Rachel who will start
five minutes early.
RACHEL GLENNERSTER: The group
the Mark was talking about is
a really integral part
of the course.
So unfortunately that is not
something that you'll be able
to get online.
But hopefully it's a chance for
you to go through, each
time we present an idea in the
lecture, you then need to go
and apply it in the case that
you're developing in your
evaluation you're developing
in your group.
And that's what all the teaching
assistants are here,
to help you go through the
case studies, but also to
develop your own evaluations.
So I'm going to start with the
general question of what is an
impact evaluation and when
should we do one.
One of the objectives of this
lecture is just to make sure
that we're all on the same page
when we start using terms
like process evaluation
and impact evaluation.
Because I realize the more I
spend time with people who are
kind of professional evaluators,
I realize that
economists and professional
evaluators use the same terms
but to mean different things,
which is incredibly confusing.
So I'm sure a lot of this will
be familiar to you, but on the
other hand, we need to make sure
that every one is at the
same level in using the terms in
the same way before we kind
of head into the
nuts and bolts.
But I also have incorporated in
this discussion about when
you should do an impact
evaluation, which is something
that comes up an awful lot
when I go and talk to
organizations who are trying
to think through their
evaluation strategy.
They've heard that they ought
to be doing more impact
evaluations.
There's lots of focus on this.
But they're expensive.
So how do they decide which of
their programs to evaluate and
at what stage to evaluate it.
They're getting pressure
from donors to do this.
But they're not quite sure
when it's appropriate.
So we'll try and cover
those ideas.
So we'll start with why is it
that we here at J-PAL are
focused on impact evaluation.
Because there's lots of other
things in evaluating our
programs that are important.
But we just do impact
evaluation.
We also only do randomized
impact evaluation.
And that's not to say that's
the only thing
that's worth doing.
We certainly don't think that.
That's what we do.
There's a reason we
do it, because
we think it's important.
But it's certainly not the only
thing that you should be
doing in your organizations.
So step back and look at the
objectives of evaluation and a
model of change, which is very
important in terms of how to
think about your evaluation,
how to design it, different
types of evaluation, how
evaluation feeds into cost
benefit analysis, and then
into why to do an impact
evaluation, and putting
it all together into
an evaluation strategy.
And then coming back
to how do we learn.
How do we make an organization
that learns from its
evaluation strategy rather
than just doing this as
something a funder wants
me to do or I have to
do to tick a box.
How do I develop an organization
that learns from
its evaluations and makes it
a better organization?
So this is the motivation
for what we do.
And I think this point is sort
of the main point here.
If you step back and you think
about how much evidence we
have in development, to make the
decisions that we need to
make, it's really quite
appalling how little
information we have.
If you think about some of the
biggest challenges in the
world in development about how
to prevent the spread of
HIV/AIDS in Sub-Saharan Africa,
how to improve the
productivity of small farmers
across the world, it's really
amazing how little really
rigorous evidence we have to
make those decisions.
And we may know that this
project may work or that
project may work, but we very
rarely know what is the most
cost-effective place to put
a dollar that I have.
If I'm choosing in HIV
prevention, if I've got to
choose between a lot of
different seemingly great
projects, what is the project
that's going to give me the
most bang for my buck?
And we really don't have that
kind of consistent rigorous
impact evaluation data in order
to make those decisions.
And that was really the reason
why J-PAL was started, because
of the feeling that we could
do so much better if we had
that kind of data.
And it's also too often the
case that decisions about
development are based on emotion
rather than data.
You can see this in proposals
that people write and the
discussions that people have,
very compelling, personal
stories, which are important,
but aren't really what we
should be making all
our decisions on.
That may be very motivating
to get people involved.
But when you're talking about
trade-offs, you've got to have
a lot more rigorous evidence.
If we had that kind of evidence,
we could be a lot
more effective with the
money that we have.
I also think it's true,
sometimes people say oh, well
you're just talking about
passing a dollar and spending
it in a slightly more marginally
effective way.
But what we really need
is more money going
into poverty really.
But arguably, potentially one of
the most important ways to
get more money to go into
poverty relief is to convince
people that the money that's
going in is actually used
effectively.
So I don't see these
as either/or.
Using the money effectively
and raising more money, I
think, both can come from
having more evidence.
So it's also important, I think,
in a way, to move from
what I think is a very damaging
and nonconstructive
debate between the aid
optimists and the aid
pessimists.
It's a very kind of polarized
debate with Jeff Sachs on one
side and Bill Easterly
on the other.
This is a quote from Jeff Sachs:
"I've identified the
specific investments
that are needed"--
from the previous sentence,
you know that
this is to end poverty--
"found ways to plan and
implement them and show that
they can be affordable."
Now if you think we
know everything
about development already--
we know what's needed, we know
how to implement it-- then,
kind of, this is the wrong
course for you.
But I think most of us would
agree that that's slightly
overstating how much information
we have about how
to end poverty.
There's a lot more questions out
there than that suggests.
His argument is, but we have
to get people motivated.
So we have got to say that
we know everything.
I don't think we have to be
quite that optimistic.
On the other hand, I think this
is way too pessimistic.
After $2.3 trillion over five
decades, why the desperate
needs of the world's poor still
so tragically unmet?
Isn't it finally time to end the
impunity of foreign aid?
So Bill Easterly is kind of
saying, oh, it has not worked.
So let's throw it all away.
We've got to find a middle
ground here.
It's just about time that
we have a development.
And they're talking about aid.
And I would argue it's
much more about
development than aid.
Aid is only a small fraction of
the money that's spent on
reducing poverty in developing
countries.
Development pessimism
is just as bad.
We've got to think more
strategically about not just
that all aid is bad or
development funding is wasted,
but how do we focus the money
on the right things.
So that's kind of
the motivation
for what we're doing.
But if you think on a very
grand scale, but thinking
about the objective of
evaluation in general, you can
think of it as three things.
Accountability, did we do what
we say we were going to do?
And again, this is true of aid
agencies, NGOs, government.
And did we have a positive
impact on people's lives?
So those are two different
aspects of accountability that
evaluation needs to speak to.
Evaluation isn't only about
accountability though.
I think it's very importantly
about lesson learning so we do
better in the future.
And that's about does a
particular program work or
not, and what's the most
effective route to achieve a
certain outcome?
Are there similarities?
Are there lessons that you can
learn across projects?
Are there similarities about
what we're finding in the
evaluation of this project
and that project?
For example, are there are
ways that you're learning
about how to change people's
behavior in health, and
agriculture, and education?
Are there similarities, sort of
underlying principles, that
we're learning about that we can
use in different contexts?
And ultimately, to reduce
poverty through more effective
programs is the ultimate
objective of evaluation.
So using that as a framework,
what makes a good evaluation?
Well, the key thing is
it's got to answer
an important question.
But it's no good if it answers
an important question but it
answers it badly.
It's got to answer it
in an unbiased way.
What do I mean by that?
I mean that it's got to
find the truthful
answer to the question.
And really to do that, you
need to have a model or a
theory of change about how the
project is working so that you
can test the different
steps in the model.
And that's the best way to
then learn the most.
If we simply say, we test
whether the project worked or
didn't work, we learned
something, but we learn an
awful lot more if you have a
specific model of how the
project is going to work and you
test the different steps
along the way.
Sometimes people say--
this is something that drives
me mad in the evaluation
literature--
you hear people saying,
well, randomized
evaluations are a black box.
They can tell you whether
something works or not, but
they can't tell you why.
I hope in the next few days,
we're going show to you how
you design an evaluation that
tells you not just whether it
works or not at the end, but
why and how, and the steps
along the way, and design it
cleverly so that you learn as
much as you possibly can from
the evaluation about the
fundamental question.
And that's about getting
the questions
right at the beginning.
And it's about doing your model
correctly and thinking
of indicators along the way that
are going to allow you to
get to all those steps and
really understand the theory
of change that's happening.
The model is going to start with
what is it we're trying
to do, who are the targets,
and what are their needs.
So in an evaluation in
development, this would often
be called a needs assessment.
And what are their needs?
But then what's the program
seeking to change?
And looking at precise and
individual bits of the
program, what's the precise
program or part of the program
that's being evaluation,
so asking
very specific questions.
So let's look at an example.
And all of this we're going
to come back to
and do in more detail.
How do you do a logframe?
Again, maybe some of you
have done that before.
Maybe you haven't.
But hopefully you'll learn more
about how we think about
doing a logframe.
So here's an example of an
evaluation that looked, a very
simple one, does giving
textbooks to children in Kenya
improve test scores was
the evaluation.
But what was the need?
What was the problem that the
program was trying to test?
Well poor children in Busia
District in Kenya had low
learning levels.
They also had low incomes.
They had few books.
That meant that they couldn't
take the books home, and that,
the theory was, made
it hard to learn.
So it was hard to learn because
they didn't have a
book in front of them in class,
but also because there
were so few, they couldn't take
them home and read up
more and do exercises at home.
So what was the input?
The input was that a local NGO
bought additional textbooks.
In order to get to your
long-term goal, you not only
need the books, you
need to make sure
that they're delivered.
Because, again, making this
chain along the way will help
you understand if it doesn't
work, where did it go wrong,
if the books were bought but
they never got there, or they
were stuck in the cupboard.
How many times have we been to
schools and oh, yes, we have
lots of books.
And we don't want them to get
messy when the children are
using them.
So they're all nicely in
their sealed package.
Well you need to be able to
distinguish if something
doesn't work, is it because it's
stuck in the cupboard?
Or was it because even when the
books are out there they
didn't get used or
they didn't help?
So the books are delivered
and used.
The children use the books and
they're able to study better.
And finally, the impact, which
is what we're about here, is
yes, you got all of
those steps done.
But did it actually change
their lives?
Did it actually achieve the
impact you are hoping to get
is high test scores?
The long-term goal would be not
just high test scores but
higher income.
And that long-term goal may be
very difficult to test in the
evaluation.
And you may use some other
work that may have linked
these in previous studies in the
same country to make the
assumption that if we got higher
test scores, it will
have a positive impact.
So again, that's a decision
when you make in your
evaluation how far along this
chain you go, if it's a
process evaluation you
may stop here.
If it's an impact evaluation
you have to stop here.
But you may not have enough
money to take it all the way
through to the finest, finest
level that you would like to.
Oh, I didn't do my little red
triangles at right point.
OK.
So I've already, in a
sense, introduced
some of these concepts.
But again, let's review them so
we know we're talking about
the same thing.
There are many different
kinds of evaluation.
And needs assessment is where
you go in and look at a
population, see what
are the issues.
How many of them
have bed nets?
What are test scores
at the moment?
How many books are there?
What's class size?
What are the problems in
your target population?
In our process evaluation, does
someone want to tell me
what they would see as
a process evaluation?
We talked a little
bit about it.
Someone?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] the
chain that you just presented
to see how you get from the
input to the output from the
output to the outcome of this
RACHEL GLENNERSTER: Right.
AUDIENCE: Are we successful in
doing that in transforming our
input into output?
RACHEL GLENNERSTER: Right.
So process evaluation looks at
did we buy the textbooks?
Were they delivered?
Were they used?
So moving inputs, outputs,
outcomes, but stopping short
before we get to the impact.
And that's a very useful thing
to do, and should be done
basically everywhere you do a
program, or at least some of
those steps need to be measured
almost every time you
do a program.
But it kind of stops short
before you get
to the impact stage.
Have we actually changed
people's lives?
We wanted to build a school.
Did we build a school?
We wanted to build a bridge.
Did we build a bridge?
We wanted to deliver things?
Did we deliver things?
But it's stopping before you
get the point of knowing
whether this has actually
changed people's lives.
So an impact evaluation then
goes to the next stage and
says, given that we have done
what we said we're going to
do, has that actually
changed things?
And this is where there
was a big gap in
terms of what we know.
There's a lot of
lesson learning
you can do from process.
But in terms of knowing what
kind of project is going to be
successful in reducing poverty,
you really need to go
this next step.
Now we used to just talk
about those three.
But increasingly, as I say as
I have more contact outside
economics and the more research
side of evaluation to
work a lot with DFID and other
organizations, other
foundations, and other agencies,
I realize a lot of
what people outside the academic
community call
evaluation I would
call review.
It's very weird.
Because they would often call
what I call something else.
But what I mean by review is,
it's sort of an assessment.
It's sending a knowledgeable
person in and reviewing the
program and giving their
comments on it, which can be
extremely helpful if you have
a good person going and
talking to the people involved,
and saying, well, in
my experience, it could have
been done differently.
But it doesn't quite actually
do any of these things.
It's not just focused in
did I build the school.
But it's asking questions
about was there enough
participation.
How well organized
was the NGO?
And a lot of this is
very subjective.
So I'm not saying that
this is bad.
It's just kind of different.
And if you have someone
very good doing it,
it can be very useful.
My concern with it, is that it's
very subjective to the
person who's going.
Yeah.
Logan?
AUDIENCE: I think that you see
so many reviews simply because
the way-- you just
mentioned DFID.
USAID, I think, is
the same way.
It's all retroactive.
The way that contracts are
awarded and things like that,
usually it's because it's a
requirement to evaluate a
certain number of programs.
And it's not until after the
program is actually done that
they decide they're going
to evaluate it.
And it's obviously cheaper to
send one person over and do
the simple review.
I think it would
be interesting.
We'll probably get to this when
we talk about how you can
apply some of the randomized
control test methodology to
something that you're
doing retroactively.
RACHEL GLENNERSTER: So just to
repeat, the argument is we do
a lot of reviews because a
lot of evaluation is done
retroactively.
What you can do at that
point is very limited.
Yes.
So this is a big distinction
between the kinds of
evaluations, is one that's set
up beforehand and one that is
after the event.
We've got this program.
We want to know whether
it works.
Basically it's really
hard to do that.
You've already kind of shot
yourself in the foot if you
haven't set it up beforehand.
If we think about what I was
saying about it's crucial to
have a theory of change, a model
about what we're trying
to achieve and how we're going
to try and achieve it, and
measuring each of those steps,
if you're coming in
afterwards, then you're kind
of adhoc-ly making up what
your theory of change is.
And you haven't set up systems
to measure those steps along
the way, it's going to
be very hard to do.
And that's exactly why you end
up with a lot of reviews.
You're in this mess.
And so you just send someone
knowledgeable and hope they
can figure it out.
To answer your specific question
though, you can't do
a randomized evaluation
after the event.
Because the whole point is
you're moving people into
treatment and control based
on a flip of the coin.
And then after the event, people
have been allocated to
the treatment or not
the treatment.
And it's very difficult to know
afterwards were these
people similar beforehand.
It's impossible to
distinguish.
They may look different now.
But you don't know whether
they look different now
because they were different in
the beginning or because
they're different because
of the program.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I was really
interested to read the first
case study because it seemed
that you were applying
randomized control
methodology.
But it seemed to be actually
done retroactively.
RACHEL GLENNERSTER: No.
It wasn't.
It might look that way.
But it was set up so the first
case study uses a lot of
different methodologies,
compares different
methodologies.
But they couldn't use all those
methodologies if they
hadn't designed it as a
randomized study at the
beginning actually.
If you've set up a randomized
evaluation, you can always do
a non-randomized evaluation
of it.
But if you haven't done it as
a randomized to start with,
you can't make it randomized.
Prospective evaluation, setting
up the evaluation from
the beginning, is very important
I would say in any
methodology you use.
But it's impossible to do it.
There are a couple of examples
where people have done a
randomized evaluation afterwards
or an evaluation
afterwards.
And that is because the
randomization happened
beforehand.
But it wasn't done because
it was an evaluation.
So if you look at the case on
the women's empowerment in
India, you will do later in the
week, that was not set up
as an evaluation.
It was set up as a randomized
program.
And the rationale was they
wanted to be fair.
So where there's limited
resources, sometimes
governments are the people who
randomized in order to be fair
to the different participants.
Some people, in this
case, will have to
get a women's leader.
In Colombia Project, that you'll
find on our website,
the Colombian government wanted
to provide vouchers to
go to private school.
But they couldn't afford
it for every one.
So they randomized who
would get them.
So that's the one case where
you can do a randomized
evaluation after the event,
when somebody else is
randomized beforehand, but they
weren't actually thinking
of it as an evaluation.
But even then, it would've
been nice to have data
beforehand.
So the last thing on this list
is cost-benefit analysis,
which is something that you can
do with the input from all
of these other things.
As they say, the piece of
information that we have so
little of is what's the effect
of a dollar here versus a
dollar here.
And you can only do that if
that's one of your ultimate
objectives when you're doing
these other impact evaluations
or these other evaluation
methodologies.
Because you need to be
collecting data about costs.
And the benefits will come from
your impact evaluation.
But you need to get your costs
from your process evaluation.
And you can put the
two together.
And you can do a cost
effectiveness.
Then if somebody else has done
that in their other study, you
can do a cost effectiveness
comparison across studies.
Or even you can evaluate a range
of different options on
your impact evaluation.
And that will give
you comparative
cost-effectiveness across.
So going into a bit more detail
in some of these, needs
assessment.
We'll look at who's the
target population.
Is it all children or are we
particularly focused on
helping the lowest-achieving
in the group?
What's the nature of the
problem being solved?
Many of these communities will
have lots of problems.
So what are we particularly
trying to focus on here?
Is a test schools?
Is it attendance at school?
How will textbooks solve
the problem?
I was talking about textbooks.
Maybe it's because they
can take them home.
Well, if that's part of your
model, your theory of change,
you need to be actually
measuring that, not just did
they arrive.
How does the service fit
into the environment?
How many times have we sat
in an office and designed
something that we thought made
complete sense, and gone out
to the field and thought,
what was I thinking?
This isn't going to work.
How does it feel for
the teachers?
Do they understand
the new books?
Do they know how to
teach from them?
How do the books fit
into the curricula?
What are you trying to
get out of this?
As they say, you want a clear
sense of the target
population.
So then you want to see are
the students responding?
If you're particularly worried
about low-performing kids, are
they responding to
the textbooks?
Students who are falling behind,
a sense of the needs
the program will fill, what
are the teachers lacking?
How are we going to deliver
the textbooks?
How many textbooks are
we going to deliver?
And what are the potential
barriers for people learning
from the textbooks?
Then a clear articulation of
the program benefits, and a
sense of alternatives.
And as I say, if you want to
look at cost-effectiveness of
alternative approaches, it's
very important to think
through not just this program in
isolation, but what are the
alternatives that we
could be doing?
And how does that
fit with them?
Is this one is the most
expensive things we're going
to try, one of the cheapest
things we want to try, and
everything in between?
So you may be thinking in this
context, is this a replicable
program that I'm going to
be able to do elsewhere?
Is this the gold-plated version
that I'll do if I get
lots of funding?
Or is this something that
I can replicate in
lots of other places?
Process evaluation, I've really
sort of talked quite a
bit about these.
So I'm going through
them faster.
And when you do an impact
evaluation, because the impact
evaluation is the last thing on
that chain, you need to do
all the other bits on
the chain as well.
You can't do an impact
evaluation without a process
evaluation or you won't
understand what the hell your
answer is meaning at the end.
So as we say, a process
evaluation is asking are the
services being delivered?
Is the money being spent?
Are the textbooks reaching
the classroom?
Are they being used?
And it's also, as I say,
important to be asking
yourself, what are
the alternatives.
Could you do this
in a better way?
Just like a company is always
thinking are there ways to
reduce costs.
You should be thinking
are their ways to
do this more cheaply.
Are the services reaching
the right populations?
Which students are
taking them home?
Is it the ones that I'm
targeting or only the most
motivated ones?
And also, are the clients
satisfied?
What's their response
to the program?
So an impact evaluation, am
i missing a top bit here?
No.
OK.
Here we go.
We're out of order.
So an impact evaluation
is, as they say,
taking it from there.
So assuming once you've got all
the processes working, and
it's all happening, but
if it happens, does
it produce an impact?
Take our theory of
change seriously.
And say what we might expect
to change if that theory of
change is happening.
So we've got this theory of
change that says, this is how
we expect things to change.
These are the processes by which
we expect, like the kids
taking the books home.
So we want to design some
intermediate indicators and
final outcomes that will
trace out that model.
So our primary focus is going to
be, did the textbooks cause
children to learn more.
But we might also be
interested in some
distributional issues.
Not just on average, we might
also be interested in was it
the high achieving kids
that learned more?
Was it the low-achieving kids?
Because very often in
development, we're just as
interested in the distributional
implications of
a project as the average.
So who is it who learned?
How does impact differ
from process?
In the process, we describe
what happened.
And you can do that from
reading documents,
interviewing people in
administrative records.
In an impact question, we need
to compare what happened to
the people who got the program
with what would have happened.
This is the fundamental question
that Dan is going to
hammer on about in his lecture
about why do we use randomized
evaluations.
We talk about this is
the counterfactual.
What would have happened if the
program hadn't happened?
That's the fundamental
question that we're
trying to get at.
Obviously it's impossible to
know exactly what would have
happened if the program
hadn't happened.
But that's what we're
trying to get at.
Just one second.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So one thing that
would seem to fit in somewhere
with the impact thing but
doesn't quite meet the
criteria that you've just
described that we've use
sometimes is this
pre-post test.
And that isn't necessarily
going to say
what would have happened.
But it will say, well,
what were the
conditions when you started?
And we extrapolate from that
looking at where we are when
we ended, what can we say
about the impact of the
intervention?
RACHEL GLENNERSTER: Right.
So that is one way that people
often try and do an impact
evaluation and measure are
they having an impact.
And I guess it can give you some
sense of whether you're
having an impact or
flag problems.
It's to say, well, what were
conditions at the beginning?
What are they like now?
Then you have this assumption,
which is that all the
difference between then and
now is due to the program.
And often that's not a very
appropriate assumption.
Often things happen.
If we take our example of
schools, the kids will know
more at the end of
the year then
they knew at the beginning.
Well would they have known more
even if we hadn't given
them more textbooks.
Probably.
So that's kind of
the fundamental
assumption you're making.
And it's a difficult
one to make.
It's also the case that we
talked to people who were
doing a project in Gujarat.
And they were tearing their hair
out and saying, well, we
seem to be doing terribly.
Our program is doing terribly.
People now are worse off
than when we started.
This was, well Mark will know
the years of the riots and
earthquake in Gujarat.
They'd basically taken data
when they started.
In the meantime, there had been
a massive earthquake and
massive ethnic riots against
Muslims in Gujarat.
Of course people
were worse off.
And that's not because of you.
So if can go either
way actually.
You can assume that your program
is doing much better
because other things are coming
along and helping people.
And you're attributing all the
change to your program.
Or it could be the case in
this extreme example.
There's a massive earthquake
and massive religious and
ethnic riots and you
attribute all the
negative to your program.
So it's a way that sometimes
people use of
trying to get an impact.
It's not a very accurate way of
getting your impact, which
is why a randomized evaluation
would help.
So, as you say, it doesn't
quite fit this criteria.
Because it doesn't
quite answer.
It says what happened
over the period.
It doesn't say what would
have happened.
It is not a comparison of what
would have happened with what
actually had.
And that's how you want
to get at your impact.
So there are various
ways to get at it.
But some of them are more
effective than others.
So let's go back to our
objectives and see if we get a
match these different kinds of
evaluations to our different
objectives for evaluation and
find out which evaluation will
answer which question.
So accountability: the first
question for accountability is
just did we do what we said
we were going to do.
Now that you can use a process
evaluation to do that.
Because did I do what I said
I was going to do.
I promised to deliver books.
Did I actually deliver books?
Process evaluation is fine
for that kind of level of
accountability.
If my accountability is not just
did I do what I said, but
did what I do help?
Ultimately I'm there
to help people.
Am I actually helping people?
That's a deeper level
of accountability.
And that, you can only answer
with an impact evaluation.
Did I actually make the change
that I wanted to happen?
If we look at lesson learning,
the first kind of lesson
learning is, does a particular
program work or not work.
So an impact evaluation can tell
you whether a particular
program worked.
If you look at different
impact evaluations of
different programs, you can
start saying which ones
worked, whether they work in
different situations, or
whether a particular kind of
program works in different
situations or not.
Now what is the most effective
route for achieving a certain
outcome is kind of an even
deeper level of learning.
What kind of thing is the best
thing to do in this situation?
And there you want to have
a cost-benefit analysis
comparing several programs based
on a number of different
impact evaluations.
And then we said an even
deeper level is, can I
understand how we
change behavior?
Understand deep parameters of
what makes a successful
program, of how do we change
behavior from health to
agriculture?
What are some similarities and
understanding of how people
tick, and how we can use that
to design better programs?
And again, that's linking our
results back to theories.
You have got to have a deeper
theory understanding it, and
then test that with different
impact evaluations.
And you can get some kind of
general lessons from looking
across impact evaluations.
And then if we want to have our
reduced poverty through
more effective programs, which
is our ultimate objective of
doing evaluations, we've got to
say, did we learn from our
impact evaluations?
Because if we don't learn from
them and change our programs
as a result, then we're not
going to achieve that.
And I guess to say that solid,
reliable impact evaluations
are a building block.
You're not going to get
everything out of one impact
evaluation.
But if you build up enough, you
can generate the general
lessons that you need
to do that.
I've said quite a lot
of this already.
But needs assessments give you
the metric for defining the
cost-benefit ratio.
So when we're looking at
cost-benefit analysis, we're
looking at what's the most
cost-effective way of
achieving x?
Well, you need a needs
assessment to
say what's the x?
What's the thing that I should
be really trying to solve?
Process evaluation gives you the
costs for your inputs to
do a cost-benefit analysis.
And an impact evaluation
tells you the benefit.
So all of these different inputs
and needed to be able
to do an effective cost-benefit
analysis.
AUDIENCE: Rachel?
RACHEL GLENNERSTER: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The needs assessment
seems to be more of a program
design sort of a
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], whereas the
remaining three are more like
the program has already been
designed and we are being
cautious, we have thought that
this is the right program
to go with.
Please design a process
evaluation for this or a
program evaluation for this.
How has that needs assessment
different from the one that
feeds into program design?
RACHEL GLENNERSTER: Well, in a
sense, there's two different
concepts here.
You're right.
There's a needs assessment
for a particular project.
We're working with an NGO in
India called [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
working in rural Rajasthan.
And they said, we want to
do more on health in our
communities.
We've done a lot of education
and community building.
But we want to do a lot
more in health.
But before we start, we want
to know what are the health
problems in this community?
It doesn't make sense
to design the
project until you know.
So we went in and did., what
are the health problems?
What's the level of services?
Who are they getting
their health from?
We did a very comprehensive
analysis of the issues.
And that was a needs assessment
for that particular
NGO in that particular area.
But you can kind of think of
that in a wider context of
saying, what are the key
problems in health in India or
in developing countries?
What are the top priority
things that we should be
focusing on?
Because again--
and I'm going to get on to
strategy in a minute-- if
you're thinking as an
organization, you can't do an
impact evaluation
for everything.
You can't look at comparative
cost-effectiveness for
outcomes in the world.
Or at least you've got
to start somewhere.
You've got to start on, what
do I most want to know?
What's the main thing I want
to change to see what's the
cost of changing that thing?
So is it test scores
in schools?
Or is it attendance?
Am I most concerned about
improving attendance?
If you look at the Millennium
Development Goals, in the
sense, that's the world's
prioritizing.
They're saying, these are the
things that I most want to
change in the world.
And there they made the
decision, rightly or wrongly,
on education, that they wanted
to get kids in school.
And there isn't anything about
actually learning.
And whether your needs is
getting kids in school or
learning, you would design
very different projects.
But you would also design
different impact evaluations,
because those are two very
different questions.
So the needs assessment
is telling you
what are the problems?
What am I prioritizing for my
programs, but also for my
impact evaluations?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do you need to make
a decision early on whether
you're interested in actually
doing a cost-effectiveness
analysis as opposed
to a cost-benefit.
RACHEL GLENNERSTER:
[INTERPOSING VOICE]
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
efficiency measure, where as
cost [UNINTELLIGIBLE}--
RACHEL GLENNERSTER: So I'm kind
of using those too easily
interchangeably.
I don't think it's so
important here.
How would you define the
difference between them?
AUDIENCE: As I understand it,
but [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
they getting a better answer.
But cost-effectiveness is
a productivity measure.
And it would mean that you
would have to, in an
evaluation say, OK, I'm going to
look at I put one buck into
this program and I get
how many more days of
schooling out of it.
Right?
RACHEL GLENNERSTER: Right.
AUDIENCE: Whereas cost-benefit
requires that it all be in
dollars or some other
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
RACHEL GLENNERSTER: So you've
got to change your benefit
into dollars.
So I'll give you an example
of the difference.
AUDIENCE: Like
[INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
RACHEL GLENNERSTER: Let's make
sure everybody's following
this discussion.
A cost-effectiveness question
would be to say, I want to
increase the number
of kids in school.
How much would it cost to get
an additional year of
schooling from all of these
different programs?
And I'm just assuming that
getting kids in school is a
good thing to do.
Right?
I want to do it.
So I'm asking what's the cost
per additional year of
schooling from conditional cash
transfer, from making it
cheaper to go to school by
giving free school uniforms,
or providing school meals.
There are many different things
I could that will
encourage children to
come to school.
But I know I want children
to come to school.
I'm not questioning that goal.
So I just want to
know the cost of
getting a child in school.
Cost-benefit kind of
squishes is it all.
And it really asks the question,
is it worth getting
kids in school?
Because then you can say, if I
get kids in school, they will
earn more and that will
generate income.
So if I put a dollar in, am
I going to get more than a
dollar out at the end?
I'm not going to flick all
the way back to it.
But if you remember that chart
that went through the process
and impact, and then the final
thing of high test scores was
higher income, ultimately am I
getting more money out of it
than I'm putting in?
I think that's sort of a
philosophical decision for the
organization to make.
It's very convincing to be able
to say, for every dollar
we put in, I think for the
deworming case that you've got
and you do later in the
week, they do both,
cost-effectiveness
and cost-benefit.
And the cost-effectiveness
says, this is the most
cost-effective way to get
children in school.
But they also then go further
and say, assuming that these
studies that look at children in
school in Kenya earn higher
incomes are correct, then given
how much it costs to get
an additional year of schooling,
and given an
assumption about how much extra
kids will in the future
because they went to school,
then for every dollar we put
in, I think it's you
get $30 back.
So you kind of have to make an
awful lot more assumptions.
You have to go to that
final thing and put
everything on income.
Now if I was doing the women's
empowerment study, then I'm
not sure that I would want
to reduce women's
empowerment to dollars.
I might just care about it.
I might care that women are more
empowered whether or not
it actually leads to
higher incomes.
So it kind of depends on the
argument that you're making.
If you want to try and make a
this is really worth it, this
is a great program, not just
because it's more effective
than another program, but that
it generates more income then
I'm putting in.
That's a great motivation.
But I wouldn't say you always
have to reduce it to dollars.
Because you have to make an
awful lot of assumptions.
And we don't necessarily
always want to reduce
everything to dollars.
So here it is.
We've just been talking
about it.
So this is a cost-effectiveness.
So this is the cost per
additional year
of schooling induced.
We're not linking it back to
dollars we're measuring.
We're just assuming that
we want kids in school.
Millennium Development Goals
have it as a goal.
we just think it's a good
thing, whether or not it
generates income.
What we did is take all the
randomized impact evaluations
that had as an outcome getting
more children in school and
calculated the cost per
additional year of schooling
the resulted.
So you see a very wide range
of different things.
Now conditional cash transfers
turn out to be by far the most
expensive way of getting an
additional year of schooling.
Now that's partly because mainly
they're done in Latin
America where enrollment rates
are already very high.
So it's often more expensive to
get the last kid in school
than the 50th percentile
kid in school.
And then the other thing, of
course, in general, things
cost more in Mexico than in
Kenya, especially when you're
talking about people.
Teacher's wages or
wages outside of
school are more expensive.
But the thing that was amazing
was that providing children
with deworming tablets
was just unbelievably
cost-effective.
So $3.50 for an additional year
of schooling induced.
And putting it this way I think
really brought out that
difference.
The other thing I should say
in comparing this is, there
were other benefits
to these programs.
So Progresa actually gave
people cash as well.
So it wasn't just about getting
kids in school.
So of course it was
expensive, right?
And we haven't calculated
in those costs.
In cost-benefit, if we reduced
everything to dollars, it
would look very different
because you've got a value of
all these other benefits.
But again, deworming
had other benefits.
It had health benefits as well
as education benefits.
So we're just looking at one
measure of outcomes here.
AUDIENCE: Excuse me.
RACHEL GLENNERSTER: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are these being
adjusted for Purchasing Power
Parity, PPP?
RACHEL GLENNERSTER: So
this is not PPP.
This is absolute.
So again, we've sort
of debated it
backwards and forwards.
So if you're a country, you
care more about PPP.
But if you're a donor and you're
wondering whether to
send a dollar or a pound to
Mexico or Kenya, you don't
care about PPP.
You care about where your dollar
is going to get most
kids in school.
So there's different ways
of thinking about it.
It sort of depends on the
question you're asking and
who's the person.
For a donor, I think this
is the relevant way.
If you're a donor who only cares
about getting kids in
school, this is what
you care about.
We also can redo this taking
out the transfers.
There's this other benefit,
the families,
of getting the money.
So this is the cost
to a donor.
So that's one way of
presenting it.
But you can present it
in other ways too.
AUDIENCE: Can you also sometimes
do a cost-benefit of
the evaluation itself?
RACHEL GLENNERSTER: That's kind
of hard to do because the
benefits may come
ten years later.
The way to think about that is
to think about who's going to
use it, and only do it if you
think it's going to actually
have some benefits in terms of
being used and not just maybe
within the organization.
But if it's expensive,
is it going to be
useful for other people?
Is it answering a general
question that lots of people
will find useful?
So often evaluations are
expensive in the context of a
particular program.
But they're answering a question
the lots of other
people will benefit from.
So the Progresa evaluation has
spurred not just the expansion
of Progresa in Mexico, but it
has spurred it in many other
countries as well because it
did prove very effective.
Although it's slightly less
cost-effective in these terms.
But it led to an awful
lot of learning in
many, many other countries.
So, I think, in that sense, it
was an extremely effective
program evaluation.
AUDIENCE: Excuse me, I just have
a question on that very
last item there.
RACHEL GLENNERSTER: OK, so this
one is even cheaper and
it's a relatively new result.
But it only works in certain
circumstances.
When people don't know the
benefits of staying on in
school, ie., how much higher
wages they're going to get if
they have a primary education,
then telling them that
information is very cheap.
And both in the Dominican
Republic and Madagascar--
so two completely different
contexts, different rates of
staying on in school, different
continents, very
different schooling systems--
in both cases it was extremely
effective at increasing the
number of kids staying
on in school.
But that only works if people
are underestimating the
returns of staying
on in school.
If they're overestimating them,
then it would reduce
staying on in school or if they
know already, then it's
not going to be effective.
So this is something that I
think is a very interesting
thing ti do, and again,
is worth doing.
But you need to first go in and
test whether people know
what the benefits of staying
on in school are.
Basically they just told them
what's the wage if you
complete primary education
versus what's the wage if you
don't complete primary
education.
It's very cheap.
So if it changes anything, it's
incredibly effective.
AUDIENCE: Is the issue of
marginal returns a problem?
Do you have to say that every
program is only relevant to
places where it's
at same level of
enrollment or admission?
RACHEL GLENNERSTER: Well this is
a sort of wider question of
external validity.
When we do a randomized
evaluation, we look at what's
the impact of a project
in that situation.
Now at least you know whether
it worked in that situation,
which is better than not really
knowing whether it
worked in that situation.
Then you've got to make a
decision about whether you
think that is useful to
another situation.
A great way of doing that is
to test it in a couple of
different places.
So again, this was tested in two
very different situations.
The deworming had very
similar effects.
In rural primary schools in
Kenya, it works through
reducing anemia.
Reducing anemia in preschool
urban India had almost
identical effects.
Getting rid of worms in a
non-randomized evaluation to
be true, but kind of a really
nicely designed one in the
south of the United
States had almost
exactly the same effect.
So they got rid of hookworm
in the 1900s.
And again, it would increase
school attendance, increase
test scores, and actually
increase wages just from
getting rid of hookworm.
And they reckoned a quite
substantial percentage.
This paper by Hoyt Bleakley at
Chicago found that quite a
substantial difference in the
income of the North and the
South of United States in 1900
was simply due to hookworm.
So this is being tested.
So ideally you test something
in very different
environments.
But you also think about whether
it makes sense that it
replicates.
So if I take the findings of the
women's empowerment study
in India where it works through
local governance
bodies that are quite active in
India and have quite a lot
of power, and tried to replicate
in Bangladesh where
there is no equivalent system,
I would worry about it.
Whereas worms cause anemia
around the world.
And anemia causes
you to be tired.
And being tired is likely to
affect you going to school.
That's something that seems
like it would replicate.
So you have to think through
these things and
ideally test them.
If I'm doing microfinance,
would I assume it has
identical effects in Africa, or
Asia, and Latin American?
No.
Because it's very dependent
on what are the learning
opportunities in those
environments.
And they're likely to
be very different.
So I'd want to test it in those
different environments.
We're falling a bit behind.
So I promised to do when to
do an impact evaluation.
So there are important
questions you need to
know the answer to.
So that might be because there's
a program that you do
in lots of places, and you have
no idea whether it works.
That would be a reason
to do one.
You're very uncertain about
which strategy to
use to solve a problem.
Or there are key questions that
underline a lot of your
programs, for example, adding
beneficiary control, having
some participatory element
to your program.
It might be something that you
do in lots of different
programs when you don't know
what's the best way to do it
or whether it's being
effective.
An opportunity to do it is when
you're rolling out a big
new program.
And you're going to invest an
awful lot of money in this
program, you want to know
whether it works.
This is a tricky one.
You're developing a new
program and you
want to scale it up.
At what point in that process
should you do the impact
evaluation?
Well you don't want to do it
once you've scaled it up for
everywhere.
Because then you find out it
doesn't work, and you've just
spend millions of dollars
scaling it up.
Well that's not a good idea.
On the other hand, you don't
want to do it when it's your
very first designs.
Because often it changes an
awful lot in the first couple
of years as your tweaking it,
and developing it, and
understanding how to make
it work on the ground.
So you want to wait until you've
got the basic kinks
ironed out.
But you want to do it before
you scale it up too far.
We've done a lot of work
with this NGO in
India called Pratham.
And we started doing
some work for them.
And by the time we finished
doing an evaluation, their
program had completely
changed.
So we kind of did another one.
So we probably did that one
a little bit too early.
But on the other hand, now
they're scaling up massively.
And it would be silly to wait
until they'd done the whole of
India before we evaluated it.
AUDIENCE: You said it may be
more appropriate to do a
process evaluation initially to
get a program to the point
where it can be fully
implemented and all the kinks
are worked out.
RACHEL GLENNERSTER:
Yeah, exactly.
If we're going back to our
textbook example again, you
don't want to be doing it until
you've got your delivery
system for the textbooks worked
out, and you've made
sure you've got the
right textbook.
It's a bit of a waste of money
until you've got those things.
And exactly, a process
evaluation can tell you
whether you've got those
things working.
The other thing that makes it a
good time or a good program
to do an impact evaluation of
is one that's representative
and not gold-plated.
Because if Millennium
Development Villages, $1
million per village.
If we find that that has an
impact on people's lives,
that's great.
But what do we do with that?
We can't give $1 million to
every village in Africa.
So it's not quite,
what's the point?
But it's less useful than
testing something that you
could replicate across the whole
of Africa, that you have
enough money to replicate
in a big scale.
So that's interesting because
you can use it more.
Because if you throw everything
at a community,
yes, you can probably
change things.
But what are you learning
from it?
So it takes time, and
expertise, and
money to do it right.
So it's very important to think
about when you're going
to do it and designing the right
evaluation to answer the
right question that you're
going to learn from.
AUDIENCE: If a program hasn't
been successful, have you
found that the NGO's have
abandoned that program?
RACHEL GLENNERSTER:
Yes, mainly.
We worked with an NGO in
Kenya that didn't work.
They just moved on to
something else.
Pratham, we actually did two
things, both of which worked,
but one which was more
cost-effective than the other.
And they dumped the computer
assisted learning even though
it was like phenomenally
successful.
But the other one was
even cheaper.
So they really scaled that up.
And they haven't really done
computer assisted learning
even though it had a very big
effect on math test scores.
And compared to anybody else
doing education, it was very
cost-effective But compared to
their other approach, which
was even more cost-effective,
they were like, OK.
We'll do the one that's
most cost-effective.
Now there are some organizations
that
kind of do one thing.
And it's much harder for them
to stop doing that one thing
if you find it doesn't work.
They tend to think, well,
how can I adapt it?
But these organizations that do
many things are often very
happy to, OK, that
didn't work.
We'll go this direction.
So we want to develop an
evaluation strategy to help us
prioritize what evaluations
to do when.
So the first thing to do is step
back and ask, what are
the key questions for
your organization?
What are the things that I
really, really need to know?
What are the things that would
make me be more successful,
that I'm spending lots of money
on but I don't know the
answer, or some of these more
fundamental questions, as they
say, about how do I get
beneficiary control across my
different programs.
The other key thing is you're
not going to be able to answer
all of them by your own
impact evaluations.
And as they say, it's expensive
to do them.
So the first thing to do is to
go out and see if somebody
else has done a really good
impact evaluation that's
relevant to you to answer
your questions already.
Or half answer or more gives you
the hypotheses to look at.
How many can I answer just
from improved process?
Because if my problems are about
logistics, and getting
things to people, and getting
cooperation from people, then
I can get that from process
evaluation.
So from that you can select your
top priority questions
for an impact evaluation
and establish a plan
for answering them.
So then you've go to look for
opportunities where you can
develop an impact evaluation
that will enable you to answer
those questions.
So am I rolling out a new
program in a new area?
And I can do an impact
evaluation there.
Or you might even want to
say, I want to set up an
experimental site.
I don't really know whether to
go this way or that way.
So I'm just going to
take a place and
try different things.
And it's not going to be really
part of my general
rollout But I'm going to focus
in on the questions.
Should I be charging
for this or not?
How much should I charge?
Or how should I present
this to people?
And you can take a site and
kind of try a bunch of
different things against each
other, figure out your design,
really hone it down, and
then roll that out.
So those are two kinds of
different options of thinking
about how to do it.
And then, when you've got those
key questions of your
impact, you can combine that
with process evaluations to
get your global impact.
What do I mean by that?
Let's go back to our
textbook example.
If you're giving out textbooks
across many states or
throughout the country,
you've evaluated it
carefully in one region.
And you find that the impact
on test scores
is whatever it is.
And then you know very
carefully, and maybe you've
tested it in two different
locations in the country and
you've got very similar
results.
So then you can say, well I know
that every time I give a
textbook, I get this impact
on test schools.
Then from the process
evaluation, you know how many
textbooks are getting in
the hands of kids.
Then you can combine the two,
multiply up your impact
numbers by the number of
textbooks you give out.
Malaria control with bed nets,
if I hand out this many bed
nets, then I'm saving
this many lives.
I've done that through a careful
impact evaluation.
And then all I need to do is
just count the number of bed
nets that are getting
to people and I
know my overall impact.
So that's a way that you
can combine the two.
You don't have to do an impact
evaluation for every single
bed net you hand out.
Because you've really got the
underlying evaluation impact
model, and you can
extrapolate.
AUDIENCE: Rachel?
RACHEL GLENNERSTER: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do you think in the
beginning when you got a
program that you're interested
in, do you think that's the
moment to think about the size
of the impact that you're
looking at that people expect?
And also, as part of that,
what's going to be the
audience, the ultimate audience
that you're trying to
get to if you're successful
with a scale-up.
And those two things, I think,
frequently come together.
Because it's the scaling up
process where people are going
to start to look at those
cost-effectiveness measures
and cost-benefit.
RACHEL GLENNERSTER: I mean, I
would argue that you've always
got to be thinking about your
ultimate plans for scaling it
up when you're designing
the project.
Because you design a project
very differently if you're
just trying to treat a small
area than if you're thinking
about, if I get this right,
I want to do it on
a much wider area.
If you've always got that in
mind, you're thinking a lot
about is this scalable?
Am I using a resource that is
either money or expertise that
is in very short supply, in
which case there's no point in
designing it this way because
I won't able to scale it
beyond this small study area.
So if that's your ultimate
objective, you need to be
putting that into the impact
evaluation from the moment.
Because there's no point in
doing the impact evaluation,
very resource-intensive
project, and
say, well, that works.
But I can't do that
everywhere.
Well then what have
you learned?
You want to be testing the thing
that ultimately you're
going to be able to
bring everywhere.
So in a lot of our cases, we're
encouraging our partners
to scale it back.
Because you won't be able to
do this on a big scale.
So scale it back to what you
would actually be doing if
you're trying to do the
whole of India or the
whole of this state.
Because that's what's
useful to learn.
And you want to be able
to sell to someone
to finance the scale-up.
So I think having those ideas in
your mind at the beginning
is very important, and as they
say, making it into a
strategy, not a project by
project evaluation, but
thinking about where do I want
to go as an organization.
What's the evidence I need to
get there, and then designing
the impact evaluations to
get you that evidence.
And people often ask me about
how do you make sure that
people use the evidence from
impact evaluations.
And I think the main
answer to that is
ask the right question.
Because it's not about
browbeating people to make
them read studies afterwards.
If you find the answer to an
interesting question, it'll
take off like wildfire.
It will be used.
But if you answer a stupid
question, then nobody is going
to want to read your results.
So we're learning from an impact
evaluation, so learning
from in a single study did the
program work in this context?
Should we expand it to
a similar population?
Learning from an accumulation
of studies, which is what we
want to get to eventually, is
did the same program work in a
range of different contexts,
India, Kenya, south of the
United States?
And that's incredibly valuable
because then your learning is
much wider and you can take
it to many more places.
Did some variation in the same
program work differently, ie.,
take one program and try
different variants of it and
test it out so that we know
how to design it.
Did this same mechanism
seem to be present
in different areas?
So there's a lot of studies
looking at the impact of user
fees in education and health.
You seem to get some very
similar results.
And again, that's even
more useful.
Because then you're not just
talking about moving deworming
to another country.
You're talking about
user fees.
What have we learned about
user fees across a lot of
different sectors?
There's some common
understandings and learnings
to take to even a sector
that we may not
have studied before.
And then, as they say, putting
these learnings in the place,
in filling in an overall
strategy of what were my gaps
in knowledge?
And am I slowly filling
them in?
So, I think that's it.
So I'm sorry the last bit
was a little bit rushed.
The idea was to kind of
motivate why we're
doing all of this.
Today you're going to
be in your groups.
The task for your groups today,
as well as doing the
case, is to decide on a question
for an evaluation
that you're going to design
over the next five days.
So hopefully that's made you
think about what's an
interesting question.
What should we be testing?
Because I think often an
underlooked element of
designing an evaluation is
what's the question that we
want to be answering with
this evaluation?
Is it a useful question?
How am I going to use it?
What's it going to tell me for
making my program, my whole
organization more effective
in the future?
So any questions?
AUDIENCE: What would you say
are some of the main
limitations of randomization?
So I assume one of them is
extrapolate the populations
that are different?
Are there other main ones
that you can think of?
RACHEL GLENNERSTER: So it's
important to distinguish when
we talk about limitations.
One is just general, what's
the limitation to say,
extrapolating beyond?
But the other thing is to think
of it in the context of
what's the limitation versus
other mechanisms?
Because, for example, the
extrapolating to other
populations is not really a
limitation of randomized
evaluations compared to
any other impact.
Any impact evaluation is done
on a particular population.
And so there's always a question
as to whether it
generalizes to another
population.
And the way to deal with that is
to design it in a way that
you learn as much as you
possibly can about the
mechanisms, about the routes
through which it worked.
And then you can ask yourself
when you bring it to another
population, do those routes
seem like they might be
applicable, or is there
an obvious gap?
This worked through the
local organization.
But if that organization isn't
there, is there another
organization that it could work
through there or not?
If you think that deworming
works through the mechanism of
anemia, well it works between
the mechanism of there being
worms and of anemia, you
can go out and test.
Are there worms in the area?
Is the population anemic because
there may be worms and
they're not anemic.
So that's a way to design the
evaluation to limit that
limitation or reduce the problem
of that limitation.
But it's not like the very
active flipping a coin and
randomizing causes the
problem of not being
able to extend it.
It's true of any impact
evaluation.
I think one limitation which
you will find in your
frustration as you want to try
and answer every single
question that you have, and you
get into the mechanics of
sample size and how much
sample size do I need--
and again, that's not
necessarily just of a
randomized evaluation, but any
quantitative evaluation--
you can test a limited
number of hypotheses.
And every hypothesis you want
to test needs more sample.
And so the number of questions
you can answer very rigorously
is limited.
And I think that's the
limitation that we often find
very binding.
Again, any rigorous quantitative
evaluation will
have that limitation.
We'll talk a lot tomorrow
about sometimes
you just can't randomize.
Freedom of the press is not
something that you can
randomize except by country.
And then we'd need every
country in the world.
It's just not going to happen.
So we'll look at a lot of new
techniques or different
techniques that you can use to
bring randomization to areas
where you think it would be
impossible to bring it to.
Compared to other quantitative
evaluations, you sometimes
have political constraints about
where you can randomize.
But as I say, quantitative
versus qualitative, the
qualitative isn't so limited
by sample size constraints.
And you're not so limited
to answer very specific
hypotheses.
The flip side is you don't
answer any specific
hypotheses.
And it's the same
rigorous way.
But it's much more open.
So very often what we do is we
combine a qualitative and
quantitative, and spend a lot
of time doing qualitative
before to hone our hypotheses,
and then use a randomized
impact evaluation to test
those specific.
But if you sit in your office
and design your hypotheses
without any going out into the
field, you will almost
certainly waste your money
because you won't have asked
the right question.
You won't have designed it.
So you need some element of
qualitative to make sure some
needs assessment, some work on
the ground to make sure that
you are asking, you're designing
your hypotheses
correctly because you've
only got a few shots.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I was wondering,
do you know of some good
evaluation or randomized
impact evaluation on
conservation programs?
RACHEL GLENNERSTER: On
I can't think of any, I'm
afraid, but eminently doable.
But we can talk about that if
you can persuade your group to
think about designing one.
Anyone else think of a
conservation program?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I don't
have an example.
I wish I did.
And you've mentioned this.
I just need to really underline
it for myself.
A lot of the programs that
my organization does are
comprehensive in nature.
So they have lots of different
elements meant to in the end,
collectively,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
What I'm understanding here is
that you could do an impact
evaluation of all of
those collectively.
But really it would be more
useful to pull them out and
look at the different
interventions
side by side or something.
Because that way you'll
get a more targeted--
RACHEL GLENNERSTER: It's true.
The question was, if you have a
big package of programs that
does lots of things, you can do
an evaluation of the whole
package and see whether
it works as a package.
But in terms of learning about
how you should design future
programs, you would probably
learn more by trying to tease
out, take one away, or
try them separately.
Because there might be elements
of the package that
are very expensive but are not
generating as much benefit as
they are cost.
And you would get more effect by
doing a smaller package in
more places.
You don't know unless you
take the package apart.
Now then if you test each one
individually, that's a very
expensive process.
Because it needs a lot of
sample size to test each
individually.
There's also a very interesting
hypothesis that's
true in lots of different
areas.
People often feel, where there
are lots of barriers, so we
have to attack all of them.
It only makes sense.
You won't get any movement
unless you do.
There are lots of things
stopping kids going to school.
There's stopping, say, girls
going to school.
They're needed a home.
There are attitudes.
There is their own health.
There's maybe they
are sick a lot.
So we have to address all
of those if we're
going to have an impact.
We don't know, the answer is.
And indeed, in that example
where we're working with Save
the Children in Bangladesh,
they had this
comprehensive approach.
Where there are all
these problems.
So let's tackle them all.
We convinced them to divide it
up a bit, and test different
things, and see some of their
own worked, or whether you
needed to do all of them
together before you changed
anything, which is a perfectly
possible hypotheses and one
that a lot of people have, but
hasn't really been tested.
The idea that you've got to get
over a critical threshold.
And you've got to
build up to it.
And only once you're over there
do you see any movement.
Well actually on girls going
to school, it's quite
interesting.
Most of the evaluations that
have looked at, just
generally, improving attendance
at school, have had
their biggest impact on girls.
I should say most of those were
not done in the toughest
environments for girls
going to school.
They're not in Afghanistan
or somewhere where it's
particularly difficult.
But it is interesting.
Just general things and
approaches in Africa and India
have had their biggest impacts
on girls, which suggests that
you've got a hit every
possible thing
is maybe not right.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
and the political constraints
[INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
RACHEL GLENNERSTER: Right.
So we'll talk actually tomorrow
quite a lot about the
politics of introducing an
evaluation or at least the
different ways that you can
introduce randomization to
make it more politically
acceptable.
That's slightly different from
whether the senior political
figures want to know whether
the program works or are
willing to fund an evaluation.
I've actually been amazingly
surprised.
Obviously we find that
some places.
There are certain partners
or people we've
started talking with.
And you can see the moment the
penny drops that they're not
going to have any control.
Because you're going to do
a treatment comparison.
You're going to stand back.
At the end of the day the
results going to be that.
There's no fiddling with it,
which is one of the beauties
of the design.
But it will be what it will be,
which is kind of why it's
convincing.
But there are certain groups who
kind of figure that out.
And they run for the exit
because there's going to be an
MIT stamp of approval evaluation
potentially saying
their program doesn't work.
That's life.
Some people don't
want to know.
The best thing I can say in
that situation is test
alternatives.
It's much less threatening
to test alternatives.
Because there's always some
alternative of this versus
that, that people don't know.
And then you're not raising
the does it work.
You're saying well, does this
work better than that?
And that is much less
threatening.
It doesn't tell you
quite as much.
But it's much less
threatening.
There's a report called When
Will We Ever Learn, looking at
the politics of why don't we
have more impact evaluations,
which was very pessimistic.
But if you look at somewhere
like the World Bank that just
put a purse of money for
doing randomized impact
evaluations out there.
And anybody in the
bank could apply.
And people were like why?
There's no incentives
for them to do it.
Program office's, they've
already got a
lot on their plate.
Why would they add doing this?
It's going to find out that
they're opening themselves to
all these risks because maybe
their program doesn't work.
Massively oversubscribed, first
year, six times more
applicants then there
was money.
It just came out of the woodwork
as soon as there was
some money to do it.
So I'm not saying every
organization is like that.
Obviously not everybody in
their bank did that.
But it was, to me, actually
quite surprising how many
people were willing
to come forward.
Now we have the luxury of
working with the willing,
which if you're working within
an organization, you don't
necessarily have that luxury.
You will see as you get into the
details of these things,
that you need absolutely full
cooperation and complete
dedication on the part of the
practitioners who were doing
these evaluations alongside
the evaluators.
You can't do this with
a partner who
doesn't want to be evaluated.
It just doesn't work.
They are so able to throw monkey
wrenches in there if
they don't want to find
out the answer.
Then it's just not worth
doing it because it's a
partnership like that.
It's not someone coming along
afterwards and interviewing.
It is the practitioners and the
evaluators working hand in
hand throughout the
whole process.
And therefore if the
practitioners don't want to be
evaluated, there's not a hope
in hell of getting a result.
We should wrap up.
A lot of these things we're
going to talk about.
But I'll take one more.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How important, or
how relevant is it, or how
much skepticism can there be
about a case where the
evaluators and the practitioners
work for the
same people or are funded
by the same people?
RACHEL GLENNERSTER: Yeah, we've
even got practitioners
as co-authors on our studies.
This is another place where I
kind of part company from the
classic evaluation guidelines,
which say that it's very
important to be independent.
I'd argue if your methodology is
independent, what you want
is not independence.
You want objectivity.
And the methodology of a
randomized evaluation can
provide you the objectivity.
And therefore you don't have to
worry about independence.
Now there's one caveat
to that.
The beauty of the design is
you set it up, as I say.
Well you don't stand
back in the sense.
You've got to manage all your
threats and things.
But you can't fiddle very
much with it at the end.
The one exception
to that is that
you can look at subgroups.
So there was an evaluation in
UK of a welfare program.
And it was a randomized
evaluation.
And there was some
complaining.
Because at the end, they went
through and looked at every
ethnic minority.
and then you know I can't
remember whether it did work
in general.
But it didn't work for one
minority, or it didn't work.
But anyway, you can find one
subgroup for whom the result
was flipped.
And that was the thing on the
front page of the newspapers,
rather than the overall
effect.
So there's a way to deal with
that, which is increasingly
being stressed by people who are
kind of looking over the
shoulder and making sure that
what is done in randomized
evaluations is done properly,
which is to say that you need
to set out in advance--
we'll talk about this a bit
later on-- but you need to set
out in advance what you're
going to do.
So if you want to look at a
subgroup like does it affect
the lowest performing kids in
the school differently from
the highest performing kids--
do I care most about the
lowest performing kid--
if you want to do that, you need
to say you're going to do
that before you actually
look at the numbers.
Because even with a randomized
evaluation, you can data mine
to some extent.
Well if I look at least ten
kids, does it work for them?
If I look at least ten kids,
does it work for them?
Statistically you will be able
to find some subset of your
sample for whom it does work.
So you can't just keep trying
100 different subgroups.
Because eventually it will
work for one of them.
So on the whole, you
need to look at the
main average effect.
What's the average effect
for the whole sample?
If you are particularly
interested in a special group
within the whole sample, you
need to say that before you
start looking at the data.
So that's the only way in which
you get to fiddle with
the results.
And otherwise it provides an
enormous amount of objectivity
in the methodology.
And therefore, you don't have
to worry so much about a
Chinese wall between the
evaluators and the
practitioners, which, I think,
is incredibly important.
Because we couldn't do the work
that we do if we had that
Chinese wall.
It just wouldn't make sense,
doing your theory of change,
finding out how it's working,
designing it so it asks the
right questions.
None of that would be possible
if you had wall between you.
So it just wouldn't be anything
like as useful.
So getting your objectivity from
the methodology allows
you to be very integrated
with the evaluation, and
practitioners to be
very integrated.